هل تشعر بخيبة أمل لأن إدارة بايدن
اختارت عدم اتخاذ
إجراء مباشر ضد ولي العهد
محمد بن سلمان
نفسه أه أنت تعرف أولاً وقبل كل شيء
أعتقد أن التقرير نفسه
رائع جدًا في قوله بعبارات لا
لبس فيها أن ولي عهد
المملكة العربية السعودية
أمر  القبض على أو قتل
مقيم وصحفي أمريكي
كان ولي العهد ملطخًا بالدماء ،
وأود أن أرى الإدارة
تتجاوز
ما تم الإعلان عنه من حيث
التداعيات للتأكد من أن
تداعياتها مباشرة على ولي
العهد
بالنسبة لي هي  من غير المنطقي أن نقول على
أقل تقدير
أنك تلاحق أولئك الذين يتبعون
الأوامر بقتل شخص ما
ولكن ليس الشخص الذي أصدر
الأوامر وأعتقد أن هناك طرقًا للقيام بذلك ،
أعتقد أن الرئيس يجب
أن يتجنب ولي العهد.  أعتقد
أنه يجب دعوته إلى الولايات المتحدة ،
ولا أعتقد أنه
يجب على الرئيس مقابلته أو التحدث
معه وأعتقد أن هناك طرقًا لمتابعة
الأصول التي يسيطر عليها ولي العهد
والتي ربما لعبت دورًا في عملية القتل هذه ،
لذا أود أن أراهم يفعلون المزيد وأعتقد
أن ذلك سيكون
متسقًا مع بطلنا
لحقوق الإنسان ويمكننا القيام بذلك دون
إحداث قطيعة كاملة
للعلاقة بين
الولايات المتحدة والمملكة العربية السعودية